all right i think it's safe to say um
that most of us wouldn't mind um having
our next guest as their valentine um he
can sing and act and dance and he's
added author to his repertoire with his
fifth children's book please welcome
back to the show our friend tay diggs
now since you were last on the show uh
you joined tick-tock
yes
and your videos are getting a lot of
attention one has just you know 11
million views plus
um i have a clip take a look
[Music]
you're a jerk and everybody's a church
where did the idea for this one come or
was it just spontaneous did it just
burst out of you were you in a mood how
did this what's the origin story
so
look i'm old right so i work with a
bunch of young people you know i have a
13 year old son
and i'm constantly being reminded uh you
know how unhip i am so i watch tick tock
with my kid so i can see what what's
going on with the young folks so
i just started to try to make up
versions of what i saw on tick tock
myself and uh
and we laugh at it you know my son is is
always recording me
but there you go you're also a huge
prankster is this true
i enjoy a practical joke yeah
back when uh uh uh my baby mama dina
manziel back back when we were in new
york doing rent i uh i left the theater
early so i could beat her home
and i hid in her closet and uh
and i scared her so badly that she
immediately burst into tears and ran out
of the apartment so it it doesn't it
doesn't sound funny when i tell it to
you right now but i laughed
[Music]